guay a placé sous une note préparatoire
le sujet et nous allons assister en
direct
nous allons donc assister en direct à
une transe hypnotique au cours de
laquelle jean pierre prévôt va comme il
l'a fait de nombreuses reprises raconter
son aventure et peut-être préciser la
nature de son contact
alors daniel buguet si vous êtes prêts
nous pourrions procéder peut-être à la
séance de façon à ce que nous puissions
établir un dialogue avec avec jean
pierre est ce que vous pensez qu'il est
je pense qu'il est prêt ça y est vous
même
tu dors toujours très profondément tu
peux toujours le sens de ma venue sultan
dont tombera tombera et insensible
absolument insensible totalement
insensible se compliquer dans n'importe
comment ça tu ne ressens absolument
aucune douleur
absolument aucune douleur absolument
aucune nouvelle j'ai toujours très bien
très calme et très attendu qui dort
profondément très profondément pour
entendre ma voix qui entend toujours le
son de ma voiture longtemps comme un
bateau n'obéit qu'à ma boîte et aurélie
racole lorsque je tenterai l'ordre est
pour l'instant tu dors très très bien
très calme et très détendu
tu as peut être transporté tu va
transporter dans le temps lors d'une
rencontre avec orgueil il a remonté d'un
rang tu remontes
et tu vas aller dans le temps un jour où
j'ai rencontré alors qu'il a un jour où
tu as pu poser des questions et total
heureuse que je poserais des questions
tu pourra répondre tout à fait car ma
santé me voir sont infondées est-ce que
tu remontes ans
c'est très bien est-ce que tu arrivé un
jour demeurant corde
tu veux parler un peu plus fort tu peux
parler tout à fait normalement un petit
peu plus fort afin que tout le monde
entende ce que tu as à dire est ce que
tu en fais trop
oui c'est très bien alors maintenant tu
vas par exemple plus demander d'où il
vient tu peux lui demander d'en deviens
tu sais que tu es comme dans un rêve
exactement comme dans un rêve et tu peux
dialoguer avec lui alors à partir de
maintenant au travers des questions que
je souhaite aujourd'hui et que tu vas
lui poser
tu vas nous donner sa réponse est ce que
je peux lui lui demander d'où il vient
tu peux nous donner la réponse merci
mais ce pécule de l'espace
je suis jamais sur la provenance si
jamais c'est l'endroit exact est en
phase de reprise tous les cas la
question pour moi jamais fourni de
réponse bien
qu'est ce qu'il est ce qu'il ya à dire
d'où il vient qui dit lei
un habitant du une autre planète hors de
la galaxie
une habitante heureux de notre planète
de la galaxie
et qu'est ce qu'ils gagnent hauteur et
ce qui fait le plus dur
plusieurs choses entre d'abord nous nous
montrer que depuis des années on élus
les moutons d'une science des faussaires
dans les moyens de les rencontrer
officiellement et non plus un réseau et
[Musique]
au tendre une perche pour éviter un
retour de 2,83
[Musique]
est ce qu'il pourrait te communiquer un
message spécial oso fait déjà communiqué
je l'avais japonais
elle est aussi lieu de naviguer ramène à
l'état de veille que jean pierre griveau
je voudrais que vous diriez une
conclusion que ceux ci selon vous donc
il existe en savoir long message je
viens de ce projet deux choses d'abord
la notion de rendez-vous de 1983 le
point de non retour et 1914 quand il
nous faudra deux de quoi s'agit-il
horrillo ce personnage d'entités donc
qui est en contact avec la tête qui est
charnelle n'est ce pas que jean qu'une
jean pierre prévôt rencontré plusieurs
fois et qui a été une illustration
apparu dans le voyage mais nous avons un
studio ici une illustration de ce
dimanche qu'il représente mais l'autre
façon photographique
c'est peut-être cette entité je crois
qu'il est un être de chair comme vous et
moi donne un message ne donne pas
d'ordre
il s'agit pour nous les terriens de
prendre conscience du fait que si nous
continuons à faire les imbéciles je dis
un mot c'est une féminisme tel que nous
le faisons en polluant à la terre en
essayant de nous entretuer les uns les
autres nous courons à la catastrophe
et attention je ne voudrais pas que nos
amis qui nous regardent se méprenne nous
ne sommes pas porteur de messages
notre prophète et autres pas du tout oui
parce qu'il y avait les boules religion
d'une secte vous l'ignorez pas qu'il ya
beaucoup de mouvements maintenant six
qui se prévalent de contact avec des
extraterrestre c'est vraiment là la
secte merelle les petits ont un certain
nombre de messages a délivré est ce que
on est en face l'une d'une chose de ce
type ou est-ce que c'est différent selon
vous
ces différents mais tous les messages
que sans que reçoivent les contacts et
ont ceci de commun ce qu'ils prêchent
l'amour des êtres les uns envers les
autres
ils prêchent la fraternité vous allez me
dire qu'un bravo il ya 2000 ans a fait
la même chose et qu'il a mal fini
je le sais le savons tous mais
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on prêche le besoin
de fatalité lorsqu'on dit tendez nous la
main et nous vous tendez peu plus le
point de sam hands et sourire et on dit
mais qu'est ce que celle ci soit là ce
sont des sondés des sectateurs ce sont
des gens qui vont faire un kilt auxerre
mais pas du tout alors comment tu es que
risquons-nous nous terriens à prêcher la
fraternité a essayé de me serrer la main
mais nous avons tout à gagner
c'est le pari de pascal decque allons
nous gagner si nous continuons à pourrir
la terre nous avions ces êtres
jadis on fait de la terre ou du moins on
décide à en faire une sorte de paradis
c'est de cette notion de la clientèle
notion dédain et nous l'avons transformé
en porcherie on peut pas à vivre
continuellement dans une poche et c'est
donc le sens du message de l'entité orio
contacté j'ai retenu donc une date qui
est le 15 août 1980 une date qui est en
harmonie d'ailleurs avec le calendrier
chrétien puisque le 15 août est une date
très important dans ce calendrier je
crois que nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir en détail sur cette affaire et
simplement posé une question à jean
pierre prévôt qui maintenant est de
nouveau à l'état de veille qui pourra
donc parler normalement
tout à l'heure ils étaient en hypnose
maintenant il est comme nous tous et
jean-pierre est-ce que vous avez la
conviction que ce rendez vous du 15 août
1980 est le véritable rendez vous celui
qui fera la décision rapidement très
rapidement
honnêtement je sais pas honnêtement j'ai
une confiance aveugle en tout ce qui m'a
été dit pascal maintes reprises nous ont
fait démonstration que c'était véridique
en plus j'ai une confiance aveugle parce
que ces gens-là à ces êtres qui nous
apporte comme disait jamie la
possibilité de se sortir de la situation
dans laquelle on est
il pourrait très bien nous laisser tel
point donc puisqu'ils viennent nous
aider il n'y a pas de raisons pas leur
faire confiance et je pense pas que
s'ils ont avancé une doute qu'à une date
que si proche de nous parce qu'elle est
au mois d'août de cette année je pense
pas que ce soit pour faire une blague
bien c'est avec
coût d'une unité que nous vous faisons
confiance et que nous demandons ce que
l'ensemble de ceux qui nous écoutent
maintenant face ce bulletin de confiance
[Musique]